biden pitches largest tax hike in
history as part of the 5.8 trillion
dollar budget request he has laid out
the tax hike as part of his 5.8 trillion
budget blueprint for federal spending in
fiscal 2023 which begins in october
under his proposal taxes will rise by
two and a half trillion dollars marking
the largest increase in history in
dollar terms the deficit would be 1.15
trillion dollars the higher taxes would
largely be borne by wall street and the
top silver of u.s households in the form
of steeper corporate rate of modified
wealth tax and a global minimum tax the
taxes outline include a minimum 20 tax
on incomes of u.s households worth 100
million dollars or more
the so-called billionaire minimum tax
would raise 361 billion dollars in
revenue over 10 years and apply to the
top
0.01 percent of households or about 20
000 americans the white house said that
roughly half the revenue stem from the
country's 700 billionaires which by the
way mansion comes out the next day and
he shuts the bill down this is a hill
story centrist mansion on tuesday shot
on president's biden plan to raise 360
billion dollars from the imposing a 20
minimum tax on billionaires which is
insane manchin says he doesn't support
the president's plan to tax unrealized
gains on billionaires which would set a
new president nothing new we have
unheard from mansion you can't tax
something that's not earned earned
income is what we're based on he said
there's other ways to do it everybody
has to pay their fair share mansion
opposition means biden proposal is
likely dead only a day after the white
house unveiled it can you imagine
you write this bill you put all this
time you market it the next dimension
says no there's nothing else you can do
about it that's great well if i'm biden
i don't do anything until i have a
conversation with joe manchin
so
uh how long have i been talking about
joe manchester four years so that's who
i am politically i'm not far left i'm
not sure i should wear a shirt that says
joe team joel mancha i'm sorry you
should you should make sure can we make
that call team joe manchin yeah i'm
actually being serious yeah
um i've been seeing mansion for years
and i'm thinking for years because i
didn't really start really getting into
politics until about 2016. and i'm not a
trump guy i would i'm not a maggot guy
sorry bro
but i was a registered independent and i
was like whatever this guy's doing i'm
not i'm not four
but what what
this guy joe manchin doing something man
he's a democrat in the reddest state in
the country freaking west virginia and
what his
it says here centrist joe manchin
that's what's so amazing about joe
manchin that's what i think is what a
synergist you talk about
we're all americans we might disagree on
a little bit here a little bit here
but like uh what was the whole rodney
can we all just get along
and and it's the fringes that are
causing all these issues in america and
i get it people have core beliefs
but thank god for joe manchin just
basically listen
you know grown-ups are here
everyone just calm down we're not just
going to be set spending like drunk
sailors you know we're going he said
he's going to come out and vote for the
the new supreme court justice uh the
black lady like there's a lot of common
sense going on with joe manchin and and
thank god there's at least a steady hand
in congress that that you know in senate
that we can kind of look towards and say
all right that's
how he kind of you got to conduct
yourself so if i'm biden to bring my
point i i say hey joe this is what i'm
pitching before i spend not smart but
days weeks months haven't put [ __ ]
together is this something you would go
for you know what he should hire his
advisor
joe if you're watching call of duty i'm
open i have to strongly disagree with
you for a second go for it when you're
talking about you know the fringe left
and the fringe right and then you know
kind of of the center which is if it
weren't for these fringe groups and
things would be a lot better but you
know when you look at the republicans
and the democrats in congress i mean
someone like mitch mcconnell is worse
than joe manchin so many of the
republicans are well i agree with you
you know and it's like these are the
people in the middle these are the
people who find common ground all the
time all this kind of stuff but there is
more unity between right-wing populist
and left-wing populists than there is
between me and a rhino republican or is
there really definitely oh yeah because
a rhino republican is fine selling out
our country whereas someone who might be
a left-wing populist doesn't want to
sell our country even if we disagree on
some of these things right and so i
think that a lot of the future of
american politics is actually going to
depend on this left-wing populist
movement because the left historically
has been this anti-big business anti-war
that type of rhetoric right and now you
have people like joe biden bernie
sanders even bernie sanders who is
supposedly one of these guys took one
and a half million dollars from big
pharma for his campaign for his
presidential run right and he talks
badly about big pharma so you have these
people who are all in the middle these
centrist types of people the the rhinos
and the regular democrats who are the
ones that are actually driving
everything up because they work together
and they're basically one of the same so
what i think is that for this 2022
midterm and hopefully for 2024 is that
we get republican candidates who are
actually conservative not like far right
extremist people that's not what i'm
saying but people who actually aren't
just going to be some walk all over me
type of republican actually get
something give an example give names
yeah who who's like all right that's my
guy i like this we're talking about
ideologically then we have tucker
carlson i mean he is the one who is
leading the charge on everything right
now if tucker carlson were to run he'd
be amazing then you have ron desantis
here in florida yes florida
do you actually look at and say that
guy's killing it or lady well i think
marjorie taylor green is one there's
something you that's who you that's the
lady yeah you're queuing on lady dude no
not q another well let's listen there
are some marjorie taylor green
has some very good things when it comes
to actually like think about the january
six prisoners right there are those
people who are rotting in those dc jails
marjorie taylor green was one of the
only people to stand up and say
something about it you know there's
things that like marjorie taylor green
when it came to some of this insider
trading brother
main person that you identify with you
say marjorie taylor will see that should
show you how how horrible i think the
situation in congress is if that if the
person yeah i will speak to that yeah
exactly that i that i identify the most
with is a marge retailer green that
should show you how screwed up things
are in my opinion i really have no faith
in a lot of the politics that we have
right now i think so much of this is
going to come down to ideological ideas
and that we put too much credence on as
a people in america on political parties
when both the republicans and the
democrats are the same thing you know if
i was a republican in congress i
wouldn't be signing any of this stuff
that other republicans are signing for
and also none of these people even read
the bills they have some 25 year old guy
who graduated from gw who's in the back
room reading this bill and highlighting
it the night before and then telling the
congressman what it is and they're
hungover doing it probably because
they're on the hill partying and it's
like that's what our political system is
i mean you look at the the spending
bills and what some of that money is
actually going to i mean like stuff
billions of dollars to countries way far
away helping other countries build walls
around their countries to keep them safe
but we can't fund our own border wall
here in america i mean none of this
makes any sense the the politics is just
let me ask you a will because you kind
of highlighted something i don't want to
just gloss over it you know we talk
about how on the on the democratic side
of things there's the moderate you know
democrats and then there's the you know
progressive aoc wing what have you right
and there's that infighting right well
you just highlighted the rhinos right um
you know the classic republican the the
reagan republican mcconnells however you
want to classify them and more the maga
wing right where do you think there's a
deeper divide
in the current political
atmosphere is it on the left or is it on
the right it's definitely on the right
yeah there's no doubt about that because
even the moderate
democrats will go along with the sjw
stuff when it comes to the left even if
people are still asking like when it
came to ocasio-cortez's green new deal i
mean that got shot down by everyone in
the senate right like it didn't pass at
all because still even moderate
democrats are asking who's going to pay
for this but when it comes to the the
social justice stuff the the moderate
democrats are still on board with the
left and when you go on twitter like you
go on right-wing twitter and you see a
lot of these people who are you know
more of the america first or not like i
i personally don't align a lot with the
mega stuff so much now but more of just
a america first agenda i guess you could
say
in a way that you know i'm tired of
spending money in foreign wars and i
want lower taxes and and things to be
able to have a single family income
provide for a family that's kind of
where i'm at but you go on there and you
will see republicans and conservatives
attacking republicans more than they
attack the left a lot of people i think
that the divide between the right right
now is really really stark if you
enjoyed this short clip click over here
to watch another short clip and if you
want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]